[Music]
in juggling wives news submitted by
beanie babies baby baby you know gave
hers away
that's a bubble that bought that burst
boat tip could have been bawling silence
for that [ __ ] how much you because sold
that one for I don't remember I don't
remember but it was a lot of money but
then it later I found out that it had to
be the specific type of beanie baby so
we're talking about like weight and
nitrous generation Princess Diana died
they came out with this special baby I
remember that purple and it was like a
rose and you had that one no so it had
to be the ones that were sold in the UK
it probably had to be mint condition
with the tag it was a lot tighter
I forgot that about and if you're a kid
none of its a mint condition no cuz you
put it in your mouth off my beanie
babies oh you're eating Cheetos and then
the cheeto dust is on the bear yeah
exactly I used to use my baseball bat a
wooden one to try to help nail like
parts of the house back in wow there's
like wood chips just missing from the
basement have a hammer on but the
baseball bats more is a funner way
that's way more fun absolutely yeah true
but a lot more fun you know wooden
baseball bat yeah had all kinds of toys
like don't worry mom I'll nail the
candles up nailing candles to the wall I
don't know my mom always needs help uh
yeah they're at my parents house but
they're not in condition at all I
remember my mom being lights take the
tag off what the [ __ ] yeah I thought the
time I'm not sure I kept to and that's
why I was like looking for that person
say I know one because I see the other
one that I kept but I I still have the
other one so it's this red bear that's
has a Mexican fight on but they're not
already soul mate they're not worth as
much as they used to be right like the
Fed kind of killed I feel like it's dead
yeah completely should have sold early
huh
well in a few generations it might be an
old relic like an antique that might
come back let it come back these things
you know what they're they don't make
them anymore Kol Pez dispensers and [ __ ]
exactly
a man secretly married to three women
got them all apartments in the same
neighborhood yeah that guy's playing on
fire the whole time I got time to be
driving into another neighborhood it was
to be a convenience world yeah start
marrying everybody on the block yeah can
you guys guess what does it have to do
with anything that's what I say it
seemed Orman this is fun no no what does
that have to do with Lillian because you
asked Thomas eat Chinese yep read it I
knew he was Chinese I knew it guys being
stereotypically you have to throw that
out yeah she's not gonna trap you I
asked Bart this that's all coming has
anyone ever seen an Asian Jewish person
I have it exactly they have to exist
though oh really you know there was a
Japanese guy in the Black Panthers yes
that's Richard Aoki his name well is he
related to Steve Aoki in the Hokie
family is he related to DJ Steve Aoki a
little bit because you're like oh he
came for money
but the idea that he came from mine
either
the idea that if you had said yes that
she'd be like that they know each other
why can't the first fact already be fun
and that's not it it's not fun sorry not
all facts are fun
do you history is not fun it's related
to pop culture G are you related to
Marie Antoinette yep I do
[Laughter]
I actually am though yeah this is over
23 it's crazy
what the [ __ ] from the Iberian whatever
and then Tula yeah um like I come from
that bloodline I just found that out
about you but government is collecting
your DNA for their cyber robot movement
and they're just like this is a fun
thing she'll probably like she's related
yep I need more [ __ ] to talk can i god
I'm related to the founder of Denny's
really yeah you wish
you wish you were the coolest a pretty
believable oh can I call my IMDB fun
facts we made it to the founder of day
my IMDB [ __ ] is [ __ ] up but I loved it
I was like reporter I was like some
shame and I was born in San Diego under
IMDB you see when you're younger yeah we
always got married like way long ago
yeah we did yeah I love it people I just
love the rod celebrity birthdays of my
guys gonna be with birthday biggest joke
yeah exactly
damn his birthday always like I want
theme as birthdays that's the stupidest
[ __ ] like why would I be on a famous
birthday website yeah yeah oh she put
some youtuber that's pretty good but
they still got the facts wrong cuz
there's like a producer with the same
name oh so it sounds like oh she's in
you know just kidding films and she
wrote seven movies pretty tight no I did
but okay I know it sounds like be in one
of the movies I do oh yeah you like it
was good it's called electric children
you should watch it right Wow
I wrote it yeah I produced it in that
damn
so there's Chinese polygamists here that
we're talking about so he was a 36 year
old man China in China and so he married
a different woman every year for three
years so he has three wives and with
each one he has at least one kid the
three-year plan and it was in three
different provinces and he got away with
it because the provinces they don't
communicate about yeah like where
emergencies
marriage Oh until one day it's always
that yeah well it's not really until one
day they all live next to each other in
1 kilometer radius in a 1 kilometer
radius 1 mile isn't it he had a lot of
money because oh he was a real estate
agent so he was able to get hit each one
of his wives pretty nice place in a 1
kilometer radius until his second wife
realized that he was texting another
woman so then she dug deeper in that
[ __ ] did he do why he'd buy three phones
he got caught at home I three phones you
bought three properties you can't have
three different phones yeah how does he
do his tax returns it's like you have
three houses on your tax return with
everyone though I mean if he's got kids
with them he's he's like oh I'm off and
I have to go away from her she watched a
documentary about Mormonism the rusical
what's good yeah five four or five wise
one should one date or something yeah
this guy is so tired he's like he's got
three wives and they're living in the
same house but in different like it's
all portioned off and to definitely know
about each other yeah but like he gets
so tired he's like like one's always mad
cuz he's spending too much time with the
other one and then the other one's mad
cuz like all none of them feel sexy
because you know cause he's [ __ ]
other women yeah competition but they
didn't they know that going into it yeah
yeah yeah but they have to in that
culture they have to like pretend to be
okay with it because they're they need
to get rid of the temptation or the
jealous the cult vibes come to me like
it's the devil that's making them
jealous it's like a blood transfusion
every other day of like wait I'm having
doubts and then the like no no no
remember the religion we're supposed to
like get rid of our dads only one with
our religion yeah that's like oh that's
right good point
all right I'll see you know I'll see you
tomorrow no they report here that he
would travel between three homes up to
ten times a week because a [ __ ]
he had them all live close what bed did
he sleep in at night he would switch it
up in a different way she would say
was a business trip because none of them
knew so you'd be like oh I need a pizza
there's over there there's a lot of
business guys that are always off on
trips like bad mistresses and so we're
out in a restaurant like I feel like you
it's really easy to get caught in a rut
like this cat came out of this guy like
sitting with his friends and he's like
he's like he'd like it
he's a Hydra pimp game and like I think
is pretty good thing he's like three
wives and the same block and they're
like oh they don't nobody like one-up
thing right exactly like maybe his
buddy's like oh I got three I got three
wives and he's like oh yeah but are they
on the same block wait why did he have
to marry them so cuz Chinese weddings
aren't they like really elaborate right
like so that's a lot of work what do you
mean by elaborate how they like it
there's a whole ceremony and like they
have like a million and all kinds of
stuff meet the family and all that [ __ ]
yeah like two homes I'll do like the
western version and the Chinese version
yeah Wow
yep so then yeah so the second wife was
someone that discovered all this and so
she followed him and then he stopped at
his first wife's home and then soon
after that the third wife found out
because she was the second wife texted
the number that kept calling the phone
so which was the third wife my god how
does it even get work done she's like
I'm gonna follow this cheating
[ __ ] she's like I'm gonna pack
me a snack bag because this could be all
day and she's like oh we're here yeah
please [ __ ] so then his first wife
divorced him now the other two women
they filed a police report against him
what yeah you go to jail for the chip
yeah it's illegal Oh
the stakes are yeah why didn't he just
keep like dating them and being a player
yeah maybe
cuz I'm like maybe I wanted because he
likes playing with fire there's a lot of
love right I just spread his seed around
increase the bloodline but the only we
can get the seed out is if they'd like
you put a ring on it because then that
gets labels right I get it
you just wanted three different like tax
breaks I think hmmmm but they don't pay
taxes in China you said it yourself
because he's got so many [ __ ] why's
he pays negative taxes I know cuz they
do mention makes a lot of money so maybe
that's why like some sort of like lose
laundering their money through the
[ __ ] wives I know at least three kids
- they're saying at least one kid with
you - what each wife that's great that's
like this plugging me document
documentary the guys are all saying that
like hey it's almost like it's almost
like ice at all of you girls on remand
I'm like here's why we're all gonna have
to have sex with each other okay
listen here we go and that's what it is
the whole time it's like last man on
earth
exactly so he's just like you got to
hear me out so to get closer to God
we're all gonna have to have get to each
other closely and live peacefully
together I'm gonna expand the kingdom
that's exactly right
it's all about expanding the kingdom and
as the guys are talking it sounds like
they don't even believe what they're
saying but they can't believe that
they're selling this [ __ ] it's like
they're selling vacuum cleaners
door-to-door it's amazing
you gotta watch the documentary do you
like as a man would you want that to
have like multiple life of course so
dream it sounds tight at first but then
you have to take care of three different
wives like bitching at home being like
why don't you do the dishes here
and it's just that yeah maybe he's like
taking his chance like three times so
he's like if this one kind of winds up
not being that great in five years and I
actually have two more oh yeah plant
plant a B and C with three kids like
this one comes out he did say that so
right now he's awaiting his sentence
because he has been officially accused
of practicing polygamy and so they're
saying or so he's saying that now he's
just gonna wait it out and see when he
gets out which one of the twos gonna
forgive him
damn he's not even like sad about it
he's like well we'll see the troll dies
that's amazing
[Music]